bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on le
rappelle dans ce contexte de révoltes
américaine la sphère adama traoré est ce
qu'elles pourraient mettre le feu aux
poudres et pourrait être le déclencheur
des émeutes c'est en tout cas ce que
craignent certainement les autorités
pourquoi émeutes je crois que c'est une
manifestation pacifiste pour justement
dénoncer les violences policières ou à
cette technique du placage ventrale qui
a coûté la vie à adama traoré mais aussi
l cédric joue via et à beaucoup d'autres
évidemment elle arrive dans un contexte
où aux états unis on est dans plusieurs
centaines plus une centaine de villes
sur des émeutes suite à la mort de
georges folle comme vous le disiez en
introduction qui a été tué par une
intervention policière là encore est
évidemment il y à la fois la solidarité
par rapport à ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis mais regardons ce qu'il se
passe en france regardons ce qui s'est
passé pendant deux ans de manifestations
de chez les jaunes le nombre de blessés
le nombre de morts également inepte cet
octogénaire à marseille qui a été tué
par un tir de grenade lacrymogène
mais aussi bientôt la fête de la musique
qui va arriver le 21 juin dès confiné
j'espère que tous les français auront
une pensée pour steegmans ya qu'à nice
au ce jeune qui a disparu suite à une
charge de police à nantes la soir de
fête de la musique donc il ya un
problème il ya un problème qui fait que
au sommet de la hiérarchie personne ne
veut s'en occuper alors il ya une gpn
qui fait des enquêtes mais regardez
comme c'est compliqué d'avoir ne
serait-ce qu'un avis d'expert sur les
raisons de la mort d' adama traoré
plusieurs expertises et contre
expertises
tout ça pour essayer de discuter une
technique criminelle le placage ventrale
qui devrait en fait ne plus avoir lieu
et qui est dénoncé par les associations
de droits de l'homme et pas seulement
par la famille d'adama traoré donc c'est
un vrai problème et je crois que
l'absence totale celui qu'on entend pas
sur ce sujet et c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner qui
évite de parler de ce sujet là alors que
aujourd'hui avec une loi d'exception on
interdit toujours le rassemblement de
plus de 10 personnes
on voit bien qu'on ne peut pas dans ce
contexte là interdire une manifestation
notamment suite à la manifestation de
samedi
des sans papiers mais aussi à maubeuge
la manifestation
des ouvriers qui défendent les usines
renault contre les délocalisations donc
le du confinement des colères le
déconfinement des luttes à est en train
d'avoir lieu
et pas seulement en france évidemment
les etats unis sont en première ligne
alors alexis paulin le ministre de
l'intérieur n'a pas réagi effectivement
à cette technique du placage ventrale
qui est décrié mais il a réagi à ces
attaques qui consisterait à dire que la
police serait raciste en france la
police qui protège dans ce pays les
femmes et les hommes de tout y compris
du racisme nous dit christophe castaner
rejoint de peu par le préfet de police
de paris didier lallement qui a adressé
son soutien aujourd'hui aux policiers je
vous propose de l'écouter avant de vous
faire réagir pour les citoyens français
que nous sommes une accusation ne suffit
pas à faire une vérité la police de
l'agglomération parisienne n'est ni
violente ni raciste elle agit dans le
cadre du droit pour la liberté de tous
je ne laisserai pas salir une
institution dont le rô le dans les
grands moments de l'histoire de ce pays
a été essentielle il n'y a pas de race
dans la police pas plus que de racisées
ou de près ce raciste il ya des
fonctionnaires qui s'engage pour la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité et cela
au quotidien
alors effectivement lexique ou d'un
compliqué ne pas faire le parallèle avec
ce qui se passe aux etats unis la police
française qui est accusé en quelque
sorte
voilà par certains de racisme qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire
mais il ya eu cette vidéo terrible avec
les mots racistes de policiers qui
disait il à kas noyer celui on n'a qu'à
lui met un boulet rappelez vous c'était
il ya pas si longtemps
même pas un mois me semble il y a
parfois des dérapages et évidemment des
débordements le problème c'est qu'il ya
un problème d'encadrement à quel moment
on autorise en fait cette parole à quel
moment on autorise le contrôle au faciès
à quel moment en fait on fait que oui il
y à des actes racistes dans la police en
revanche et là je suis d'accord avec le
préfet l'allemand c'est une institution
la police on peut pas dire la police ou
les policiers c'est une institution en
plus de la diversité qui recrutent dans
la france entière
vous avez en fait une population qui est
représentatif de ce qu'est la france au
sein de la police donc oui il ya des
racistes au sein de la police comme il
ya des racistes au sein de la population
française le problème encore une fois
vient de là
hérarchie c'est que les racistes ne
peuvent pas être policier de la
république ils ne peuvent pas rendre ce
service public qu'est le maintien de
l'ordre et la protection des civils donc
on a un vrai problème qui est celui en
fait des dénonciations et des actions
suite aux actes racistes qui ont pu
avoir lieu au sein de la police
nationale
alors il ya les enquête de l'igpn là
encore une fois elles sont elles sont
extrêmement décrié mais surtout il n'y a
pas de paroles assez forte
la part de ce préfet l'allemand qui par
exemple à une époque lors des
manifestations dédiées jaune par les
deux camps et disait à une citoyens qui
n'étaient pas dans le même camp que
cette femme c'est inacceptable de la
part d'un préfet de par les deux camps
donc il a raison de recadrer de dire que
la police est une institution et on ne
peut pas dire la police est raciste
c'est faux mais ce qui moi vous pose
problème et qui nous pose problème à
tous et c'est pour ça que il ya autant
de monde aujourd'hui devant le parvis du
palais de justice
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de dénonciation à
ces sortes de la part du ministre ni
préfet ou même du président de la
république de ces dysfonctionnements qui
sont graves parce que ils remettent en
cause la confiance qu'ont les français
dans la police et il est temps d'arrêter
on ne peut pas faire de la police un
ennemi de l'intérieur
on ne peut pas entendre tous les fixes
sont des paul comme sahara
bastard
c'est faux la police doit être respectée
mais pour ça elle doit montrer du
respect et elle doit surtout être
exemplaire et aujourd'hui on a tout sur
place donc s'arrêter à la tête de l'état
on a tout sauf l'exemplarité dans la
façon dont est gérée en fait cette
institution donc c'est ça qui est
dangereux et extrêmement grave alexis
poulard vous sembliez étonné tout à
l'heure quand j'ai prononcé le mot
émeute en tout cas je vous posais la
question de la possibilité que ça que
c'est cette issue là on se souvient
quand même des épisodes dramatiques de
villiers le bel en 2005 où deux jeunes
on avait trouvé la mort dans ce fameux
générateur électrique save et crée les
émeutes dont se souvient situation vous
l'avez dit vous-même tendue en france
avec une situation économique très
compliqué ce qu'on doit craindre une
escalade dans les prochains temps dans
notre pays est ce que vous le craignez
oui et je suis pas le seul
pour avoir parlé avec des syndicalistes
policiers ils sont très conscients que
l'automne risque d'être particulièrement
agitée 11% de récession économique
beaucoup de chômeurs de nouveaux
chômeurs qui vont arriver un climat
mondial qui est celui de la contestation
mais ça depuis 2010 9 déjà dix pays qui
étaient dans la rue contre leurs élites
corrompues deux ans de manifestations
tous les samedis de gilet jaune qui
rappelez vous manifestez pour et bien
sauver le pouvoir d'achat éviter le
déclassement contre la taxe carbone est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on entend la
petite musique du groupe d'économistes
mis en place par le président de la
république
et bien c'est le retour de la taxe
carbone c'est travailler plus et payer
moins
le chantage en fait aux salaires en
disant vous allez être obligés d'être
payés moins pour garder votre emploi
donc le chantage à l'emploi
tout est là toutes les recettes en fait
les ingrédients pour une déflagration
sociale d'une ampleur inédite est
malheureusement encore une fois si vous
regardez en haut à l'elysée à matignon
et ailleurs on n'a pas l'impression
d'une volonté de concorde mais plutôt
d'une volonté d'affrontements qui est la
même en fait depuis deux ans donc je
suis extrêmement inquiet je suis pas le
seul au sein de la police et également
les gens sont inquiets de ce qui
pourrait se passer je pense que l'été va
être chaud il va falloir être vigilant
sur cette récession énorme qui arrive et
que bien septembre risque d'être un mois
noir en termes de contestation sociale
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
cofondateur du monde moderne d'avoir été
avec nous